[Music]
Bonjour it's raining it's cold but we're
in Paris and it's beautiful today we're
in New York it's rather cold but very
sunny and we're really happy to be here
mina-san konnichiwa nihon a Yoko saw
g'day and welcome to a special episode
of sara's music from Down Under today
we're in Norway where it's absolutely
freezing but I'm glad it's absolutely
freezing because I'm standing on a fewer
hi and welcome back to sarahs music
we've been all around the world in some
very inspiring places and I'm in a very
inspiring place right now here in Berlin
it's our editing studio for Sara's music
and I'm here with our picture editor
Kevin shiner all right Kevin you're in
your great editing chair and which place
should we revisit first how about how
did you get to Carnegie Hall again
practice practice practice that's right
[Music]
you see where's the Carnegie Hall oh ok
thank you start spreadin excuse me
you're from New York yes I am how do we
get to Carnegie Hall ah practice
practice practice okay this'll work
thank you off we go
I wake up in a city that doesn't sleep
we're going in but not through the main
door we're going into the stage door
[Music]
so we're backstage at the carnegie hall
and i'm just about to go on to the stage
this is where the musicians wait before
the concert and it's an amazing feeling
to walk out onto this stage come and
have a look you thank you hi isn't this
absolutely amazing
I'm on stage with leaf over and he's
just finished the first office of his
rehearsal and I'm dying to find out why
why you think this acoustic is one of
the best in the world it has a certain
beauty it's very very difficult to
define it I find especially in the soft
nuances there is some glow to the sound
here and what is really magical about
that is that I mean it's a 2800 seat
hole and when I play a recital here I
feel I can play as soft as I want and I
feel the Sun comes back from you know
the last seats of the world it's maybe
that's an illusion but as the sound
tells me that it carries you post it on
your Instagram feed something that
touched me very much you said after the
first notes you have the feeling that
this whole set whispered welcome back
and I know exactly what you mean because
when I come on here on stage to play for
the person we just did anything wow it's
just a mean even welcome home hey
welcome home you know it's like this
homecoming if there's something so
comfortable and homely about the sounds
today we're up above the skyscrapers in
New York on the roof of carnegie hall in
the resnick education wing
[Music]
music education is really important to
Carnegie Hall Carnegie's while Institute
produces an extraordinary range of music
education and community programs for
young people of all ages from small
children to music students from all over
New York City and all from very
different social i absolutely love New
York it's a city full of music as is the
next city we visited which needs no
introduction today we're at the maison
de la radio where there's a fantastic
new concert hall and i'm really excited
to be meeting catcher marla beck the
lebesgue sisters are a french piano duo
and they've been playing together since
childhood and have had an amazing career
come in come in yeah no really it's
worried you girls weren't gonna come
you're late i showed you the way yes
[Music]
girls can I see the dresses oh wow and
the other one yes ok well get changed
into the men come on you want to see the
shoes we want to see the shoes oh oh my
goodness look at those and where my
years on yes thank you
[Music]
who's he
after the hot latin rhythms in Paris we
can now cool down with a complete change
of scenery
[Music]
[Music]
musical instruments made out of ice it
was amazing to watch them being built
and of course to hear what they sounded
like Norway was great but it was really
freezing out there it was also a little
chilly where we went to Australia to
film the Australian world orchestra in
Sydney it was July but it was winter
Kevin hmm you ready to go back down
under here we go
[Music]
the guest conductor for the concert at
the Sydney Opera House was none other
than my boss at the Berlin Philharmonic
so Simon Rattle
[Music]
[Applause]
on the way back from Sydney to Berlin we
stopped off at the Pacific music
festival in Sapporo Japan we got to wear
the traditional kimonos for our
performance with the horn section whose
idea was that it was hot so we're on our
experience Japan trip today and we are
allowed the whole horn section is being
dressed up in kimonos god I can't quite
imagine what its gonna be like to play
in this kimono because it's pretty tight
in here and it's pretty hot in here as
well
[Music]
[Music]
that's all from Sarah's music for today
we had a great time in Sapporo I hope
you did too sayonara from Japan an alpha
design from our Berlin editing studio oh
wait a minute I almost forgot kevin has
edited so many Sarah's music horn
challenges isn't it about time he tried
one of his own Kevin you know what to do
with very great profession Sarah all
right yeah